et voilà c'est tout le monde en parle
alors il m'a nouvelle saignée voix
bonsoir alors toute la semaine vous
attaché de presse c'est à dire ceux du
film et puis vous attaché de presse
personnel m'ont téléphoné en disant que
vous aviez peur de devenir dans cette
émission ce soir
pourquoi parce que vous avez peur de
perdre votre mystère on n'en est pas du
tout c'est que vous aimez bien torturé
les gens ah oui mais pas les tv est ce
que ça fait de l'audimat 1 et j'ai pas
envie d'être fil de vos victimes
oui vous avez peur de moi j'ai pas peur
de vous mais j'ai envie de me servir de
vous mais je veux pas que vous vous
serviez de moi cérébrale
on va faire quelques questions comme ça
se fait très gentil vous préférez quand
vous confondre avec mathilde seigner ou
avec ludivine s'allier avec personne
est-ce que vous avez préféré être la
belle soeur de laurent gerra ou d
anthony delon je réponds pas ces
questions
ah bon pourquoi pas ce que c'est ça
m'intéresse pas ah bon voilà bien la
vigne qui était drôle là allez-y banon
voulait pas répondre mais l'édile
j'écoute mais non mais si vous répondez
pas j'ai pas osé jane va répondre
mais je vous la pose when they fall dira
qu'elle est bête après 6 et a besoin
d'amour ça c'est moi de vous torturer la
whey away les rôles funds a changé à
verser inversée non je vais simplement
savoir vous avez déjà couché avec votre
mari pour avoir un rôle mais là je rêve
je rêve là vous vous sentez éminemment
supérieur d'un coup non supérieure de
quoi de vous non je trouve ça vraiment
stupide quoi je vais pas vous épanouir
quand même
non non
je vais pas pleurer je suis venu pour
défendre le film dans lequel je suis
d'accord ça aurait été dommage
effectivement vous veniez pas parce que
vous êtes excellente dans le film c'est
vrai c'est rare de voir dans un rôle
public qu'il m'a fait peur
j'y connais rien c'est rare de voire
excellentes et là il faut vous pouvez
réparer l'ambiance qui est très dégradée
thierry non c'est vrai c'est assez
inattendu de quoi de me voir dans un
rôle comique
oui c'est vrai que il vend à une bonne
idée voit en le plan c'est yvan non mais
je pense que pour vous c'est un film
aussi important que le place vendôme
parce que j'aurai place vendôme ça vous
a révélé un petit peu et ce film va être
amélioré aussi important oui je pense
mais en même temps je pense que j'ai
j'ai fait du très bon travail dans
frantic ou dans lunes de fiel mais quand
caen s'est mis en scène par roman
polanski
les gens et surtout les critiques ne
voit pas ça ils voient pas le travail
ils jugent comme une commune femmes et
pas comme une actrice et donc voila quoi
ça va là ouais ça va il vous ça va moins
ça va très bien je vous faire une
interview complexe d'actrice onyalla
pourquoi essayons sait on
emmanuelle seigner est ce que vous êtes
gêné non non non non mais je suis je
vous dis oui je suis gêné pour emmanuel
parce que je la sens mais je la sens pas
tranquille quoi non mais moi ça me
crispe ah ouais moi aussi a manqué tous
prix angie vous êtes crispé et pourtant
on parle pas français tu dois te dire
une sale ambiance moi c'est commence
fort bien ce domaine
la gloire d'instaurer un climat de
sympathie de convivialité c'est ton
travail thierry oui bah là j'essaye ah
ouais mais vas-y on l'a fait c'est une
interview pas non non vous les affaires
vous oui mais je parle dans le fond je
voulais pas le faire mais pourquoi vous
sais même pas ce que c'est non mais
j'aime pas trop ces petites interviews
là ça vous plaît pas ce qu'est ce qu'on
fait mais aussi les émissions qui
commence mal et qui se terminait bien
les invités noël j'adore il peut y avoir
aussi un renversement de situation on
peut partir sur une super bonne
impression aussi mettons ça dans un coin
de notre tête c'est pas impossible
c'est mal barré mais c'est pas possible
non c'est pas la totalité viergela met
là et puis si vous la sentez en or de
trois ans toute façon la triche
la fiche ne bougera pas je trouve
hallucinant ici voilà c'est pour vous
bon on passe à angie alors jarny notre
fiche de côté pour alger pascal fera pas
non plus mais alors angie d'aller re
bonsoir donc dans le film vous êtes la
maîtresse divan attal et vous êtes une
comédiens non professionnels
le vrai métier ses secrétaires de
rédaction
oui ça se travaille dans une maison
d'édition et entre autres je m'occupe
d'une revue qui s'appelle la revue de
car la revue littéraire voilà et est en
fait c'est une bonne idée d'avoir pris
quelqu'un qui n'était pas comédien parce
que ça donne du flou à votre personnage
est une espèce de fantasme paiement là
en fait quand j'ai écrit le scénario je
l'avais écrit ce personnage comme
c'était pas un personnage incarné au
scénario c'était quelqu'un c'était une
idée d'une eau de vie quoi il a du coup
à chaque fois que je rencontrais une
actrice professionnelle
enfin qu'on connaissait elle venait avec
un background toujours on la connaissait
on connaissait ses films mais c'était
c'était à côté du rôle que je cherchais
puis j'ai eu la chance de croiser angie
et puis tout d'un coup je me suis dit
que je reprends voilà et puis je les ai
vus à lille charlotte et malgré
le fait qu'elle soit quand même assez
différente je trouvais qu'il y avait une
chose en commun et ça me plaisait
voilà de tenter l'expérience j'ai
demandé à une vie de venir faire une
lecture et puis elle s'est prêtée au jeu
et elle est extraordinaire dans le film
hannah des scènes en plus émotionnelle
et pour quelqu'un qui a jamais fait ça
je trouve qu'elle s'est donnée à fond et
je la trouve vraiment j'ai complètement
craqué sur votre maîtresse
on va dire ça comme ça
professionnellement professionnellement
j'ai un cadeau pour toi c'est quoi c'est
un blouson parce que l'ibère va arriver
c'est un beau c'est gentil si gentil
parce que chaque personnalité yvan
personnel
devant
oui
je te rassure il allait vers 6 liban ah
oui bien sûr dans la daïra c'est pas
bravo
je te prête pour l'interview l'a
toujours pas là on peut essayer la
première question
ouais les y aller première question je
reviens sur vous tous été après angie
donc c'est l'interview complexe
d'actrice emmanuelle seigner est ce que
vous êtes déjà dix actrices
finalement c'est peut-être pas mon truc
oui voilà
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit j'ai des
gros mollets non je lui ai déjà dit
j'aime pas à mes yeux
non oui on en a
vous aviez la science sont donc c'est là
c'est pas bien c'est complexe d'actrice
là autant jeter pente au départ la matte
en chine pour lui est ce que vous êtes
déjà dit mais qu'est ce qu'il me
trouvera man est ce que vous êtes déjà
dit ma soeur m'a fait honte
si vous êtes déjà dit je suis jalouse de
charlotte
non est ce que vous êtes déjà dit
j'aimerais ampat interdite elle est bien
sa table et je lui ai déjà dit
j'aimerais qu'on me filme comme ivan
film charlotte
oui je vous ai déjà dit je n'aurais
jamais dos car c'est la honte devant mon
mari non je vous ai déjà dit si ce qui
ne fait pas un carton j'arrête le cinéma
est ce que vous êtes déjà dit la
critique ne m'aime pas oui est ce que
vous êtes déjà dit qu'elle compte
laurent gerra
bon bah voyons mais elle était bien
maintenant voilà bah voila je suis sûr
qu'on va dire c'est qu'en club dans le
fond il brûle comme ça sert non mais
c'est vrai j'ai bon enfant gagne à être
connu j'ai bon sens et bonifie alors en
duo revient sur nos tifosi je suis
désolé et honteux
est-ce que vous avez bon est-ce que vous
avez repris le boulot à la revue
littéraire et alors mais c'est très bien
j'aime beaucoup tout a changé tu te la
pètes non non non vous vous sentez
encore plus belle depuis que j'avais
fait ce que je sais pas non je crois pas
non le plus grave c'est quoi pendant le
tournage de voir comment ça se passe un
tournage bien ouais c'est un vrai pro et
le moins supportable c'était quoi les
moins supportable
je sais pas on dit souvent que c'est la
tente mais bon en même temps c'est bien
aussi dans le monde puisqu'on a le temps
de se concentrer voulait recommencer
oui oui vous plaît la wii et la promo
télé être ici ça vous plaît ou ça veut
dire mais je suis passé la première fois
des alors jusqu'à présent je peux dire
après ça va matin oui
non très bien non mais c'est vrai que
c'est difficile quand même de venir à la
télé mais je sais moi je viendrai pas
dans ses missions ses surnoms
alors j'aurai pas majorer leur jeter la
connerie bon génie plein de nouveaux
sons pleurs les enfants cette année donc
tient jusqu'à dimanche l'avancé
les intrus dans la bo du film qui est
bien c'est quoi
ciao